on Thursday e-commerce giant Amazon made
a surprise announcement it withdrew
plans to build a new headquarters here
in New York while the project in the
Queens neighborhood of Long Island City
was welcomed by many it also generated
fierce local opposition here to talk
about what the decision means is Derrick
Thompson senior editor at the Atlantic
Derrick good morning good morning so you
write that New York City and Amazon both
got what they deserve explain that I
think that a popular view right now is
that this is a tragedy for the city that
we have lost out on 25,000 jobs a
headquarters from a major tech giant in
a world that this is a huge loss in the
bigger picture though New York is gonna
be fine
Amazon is going to be fine and the city
does not have an employment problem it
doesn't even have a tech employment
problem Google is expanding at a rapid
clip Amazon already has 5,000 jobs here
New York City has a household
affordability problem right and the city
leaders should focus on the problems the
city has make it a desirable location
for any company to come to without being
bribed with billions of dollars of
corporate subsidies and start with that
even playing why do you call this a
disaster from the start I quote us after
from the start because this is kind of
like a potluck of political
miscalculations like everybody brought
their own Bezos from the beginning
Amazon typically such an effective
company a marshalling public opinion a
disaster with hq2 telling people this is
gonna be a way to potentially revitalize
small cities and they ended up just
choosing New York City and Washington DC
suburbs that's number one number two I
think that Cuomo and de Blasio the mayor
of New York City
dramatically miscalculated the political
temperature of Queens at a moment of
left-wing agitation in the Democratic
Party and in a moment when you have a
lot of people who are worried about
affordable housing and see affordable
housing subsidies being taken away from
people a trillion dollar company that's
not a good look from a mayor who ran on
affordable housing well well this is how
cities do business they give
corporations their own form of welfare
so in a city like New York City that is
like in itself
it's wealthy right how do you how do you
how are you supposed to do this right
the way that cities do business with
regard to corporate subsidies is bad
business every single year American
cities and states spend ninety billion
dollars on corporate subsidies that's
not creating any net new jobs that's
just dragging jobs that already existed
across state lines the vast majority of
these subsidies are given to companies
that were going to move jobs that city
anyway so why do they do it they do it
because they're desperate for political
wins but it's a it's a zero-sum game is
there any evidence that the subsidies
really work there is very little
evidence the subsidies work in fact
there's more evidence the subsidies
don't work that they essentially pay
companies to do that which they were
going to do anyway
Seattle's giving Boeing nine billion
dollars in subsidies in the area that it
was actually found in New York City the
capital of advertising in America paying
a company that's expanding into
advertising three billion dollars to
expand into a city that was probably
coming to anyway in terms of a large
number of jobs I think that this is an
extremely wasteful anti-capitalist
anti-free market way to think about
corporate development you build the best
city you can with municipal investments
and then the companies make their own
decisions that's the free market tell us
how you really think Derek time thank
you